MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
It is my sincere pleasure
to introduce Jason Matthews.
Jason is a retired officer
of the CIA's Operations
Directorate, over a 33
year career in the CIA.
He's served in multiple
overseas locations
and engaged in clandestine
collection of national security
intelligence, specializing
in denied-area operations.
Jason has lived
all over the world,
and I'll let him tell you
a little bit about that.
But he is the best-selling
author of "Red Sparrow"
and he has just come
out with a sequel
to his book called,
"Palace of of Treason".
So if you could all please
help me welcome Jason Matthews.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON MATTHEWS: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And I'll start
off today just asking him
a few questions about
his career in the CIA,
asking him about his
transition into being
an author, and so on.
And then we'll open
it up to all of you
for you to ask him
anything you'd like.
I will ask, the
book is fairly new,
if you could please
avoid spoilers
on "Palace of Treason".
I think people watching this on
the live stream and on YouTube
would really appreciate it.
Now I didn't include this
in the intro but I did just
find out that
"Palace of Treason"
is now also in "New
York Times" best seller.
Isn't that right?
JASON MATTHEWS: Yeah.
The list came out
yesterday and I
got a couple of
congratulatory calls
from the editor and my
agent, who's always thinking
in terms of 20% to him.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
congratulations.
That is great news.
And I think I'm going
to start off just
by talking about--
if you will-- your,
I'll call it an
explosion onto the scene.
Right?
You came out with
your debut novel,
it was a tremendous success.
All the reviews in
the "New York Times",
"Washington Post"
were quite stellar.
And how did that
come across to you?
I mean, was it a surprise?
Was it like a, of course,
I knew this all along.
How did you receive that?
JASON MATTHEWS: No, what
amounts to a second career
has come as a great surprise
and a pleasant surprise.
I was immensely lucky to find
a great literary agent in New
York City, immensely
lucky to have
had Scribner, the publisher,
accept the manuscripts,
both of them.
Incredibly lucky to
have been assigned
a great editor who is himself
a novelist, steel-trap mind
and a great guy.
And also lucky to
have had the books
critically accepted pretty well.
It's a very hard industry
to break into it.
And if your book
comes out anywhere
near the time the last
Stephen King novel comes out,
he sucks all the
air out of the room.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So there's like,
maybe two weeks out of the year
where you can publish a book?
[LAUGHTER]
JASON MATTHEWS: Exactly.
He's prolific.
He's great, but he
keeps pumping them out.
MALE SPEAKER: And as I
mentioned in the intro,
you were in the
CIA for 33 years.
And "Red Sparrow",
"Palace of Treason",
they are spy thrillers, correct?
And can you talk a
little bit about how
you were able to bring your
long tenured career in the CIA
into your new
adventure as an author?
JASON MATTHEWS: Certainly.
The career, and
parenthetically, my wife Suzanne
is in the audience.
She's also a 33-year
veteran of the agency.
We met on the job
and we were what
they called a tandem couple.
But the career is
very experiential,
it's very intense.
It's 24/7, like a firefighter,
or a policeman, or a jet pilot.
And after 33 years, especially
traveling overseas and doing
what we do-- and we can
talk about that a little bit
too-- when it comes to a
stop, it's a full stop,
and it's a pretty
tectonic change of life.
So for me, I started
writing almost for therapy,
thinking of war stories
and putting them down.
And in the final analysis, it
was either write, go fishing,
or learn jazz-hands
dancing, and I don't fish.
So I started writing.
MALE SPEAKER: And
both books focus
on a pair of agents, one
American and one Russian,
Dominika.
How much of yourself did you
put into your main characters?
JASON MATTHEWS: The
main characters,
in fact, all the characters
in the plot itself,
is basically a fictitious
mosaic of people I've known,
places we've lived
in, things we've
done, because we had
to get both manuscript
totally reviewed
and approved by CIA.
They have an office called
the Publication Review Board
and they were very careful
and we worked very closely so
that there's no inadvertent
airing of classified
information.
There's nothing
classified in the book,
but the trade
craft is real life,
the vocabulary is insider,
and a lot of the people,
and the places,
and the activities
are based on my career.
MALE SPEAKER: How have your
friends, and colleagues,
and current and
past coworkers, what
have been their
thoughts on the book?
People who are in the CIA?
JASON MATTHEWS: Most of
them have enjoyed the books.
I get the inevitable
telephone call or emails,
next time, man, you have
to put this in, or put me
in the next book.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON MATTHEWS: For the most
part the idea of the reaction
is positive.
There are a few purists who
say, you know, when you retire,
you should really
just retire and not
write about the life and things.
But in reality, these two books
are my love letters to CIA.
I'm celebrating a career,
worked in an elite organization,
did arcane work and
served my country.
So that's what these
books are about.
And celebrating
the New Cold War.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll get to that.
I'm sure lots of us have
plenty of questions about that.
But you did touch on
the CIA Review Board.
And I think we would all love
to hear a little bit more
about that.
What is the review process like?
What are their main
concerns and main objectives
when they're
reviewing your book?
And were you able to
proactively prevent them
from redacting anything?
JASON MATTHEWS: Yeah,
it's less a matter
of preventing them
from redaction
or them taking too heavy a hand.
But we worked very
closely together.
But as an example, the
CIA training facility
is called the Farm.
It's down in
Tidewater, Virginia.
I can, in a fictional novel,
I can describe the Farm,
put the characters in the
Farm, go through training
at the Farm.
But I'm not allowed to name
the river on whose banks
the Farm is located.
And why, I asked the PRB.
They said, well, it would
confirm the location.
I said, but look in Wikipedia.
Google the damn place.
It's all over,
including that river.
No, no, no.
It would confirm it.
It's classified.
You may not add it to your book.
So I had images
of Vladimir Putin
in the basement of the
Kremlin, slapping his forehead,
reading "Palace of
Treason" saying,
so that's where the Farm is.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: I think
that's a great transition
point to talking a little bit
more about the New Cold War.
And Vladimir Putin is a
very polarizing figure.
He gets constantly
lampooned on TV.
He has done everything
under the sun,
and now he is a character
and your novels, right?
As much as people like to joke
about him, at the same time
he is a world leader
and he does have
a tremendous impact on the
lives of millions of people.
How is the time
that we're living
in now and the current
political landscape,
how does it compare to
the political landscape
when you were an
operative, and when
you were involved with the CIA?
JASON MATTHEWS: That's
a good question.
I maintain that there's
a new Cold War going on.
A Cold War is
basically, it describes
the bilateral relationship
between two states.
And I believe that the level of
espionage between two countries
is a good barometer of
how the Cold War is going.
And the Russians are
spying their heads off.
In the summer of
2010, you remember
the FBI in New York arrested
11 Russian illegals.
These are deep cover
sleeper assets.
They had lived in the
United States as Americans,
as our neighbors,
for a decade trying
to develop access to secrets.
Last January the FBI,
also in New York,
popped a Russian-- by
popped, I mean arrested--
a Russian banker who was
an intelligence officer
and he was nosing around the
New York Stock Exchange trying
to get a handle
on the high volume
electronic network
system, exchange system,
in Wall Street.
He was also looking
into how the Russian
oligarch's-- Putin's buddies--
funds had been frozen
for sanctions in
the United States.
I think they were
contingency casing
for maybe some cyber attack.
So the Cold War is
moving, is still going on.
Putin famously said, you know,
Russia never lost the Cold War
because it never ended.
A lot has been
written about him.
He's a fantastic character
and I thank him every morning.
I thank Vlad for being Vlad.
He's a great
character for a book.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
Also, we're at Google, right?
We all work in technology,
either directly or indirectly.
And technology has--
every day it's constantly
changing the game, it's
changing espionage,
it's changing
intelligence, and so on.
Could you talk a little
bit more about how
the CA today, with drones and
collections of information
and so on, compares to
the CIA of the Cold War
with more of that
human intelligence
type of interaction?
JASON MATTHEWS: Coming from my
generation and from my optic,
there's no replacement for
human intelligence, what
they call HUMINT.
That's what we do we.
We're sort of like
clandestine journalists.
We look for a story, a
reporter looks for a story.
We have Intel requirements.
A reporter will find a
source in the mayor's office
because there's a
scandal going on.
We have intelligence
sources and we recruit them.
A reporter will file a story.
We file Intel reports.
And a reporter will
protect his source,
to the extent that
maybe he or she will
go to jail before they reveal
the identity of his source.
We have what they
call tradecraft, which
is a fancy word for
skulking around,
to prevent people
from understanding
contact between an intelligence
officer and a foreign source.
So clandestine
journalism and HUMINT
are still sort of
the gold standard.
Now you have imagery
intelligence, pictures taken
from satellites called IMINT.
You've got signals intelligence,
sucking everything out
of the SIGINT, and
other kinds of INT's.
But as much as
technology has advanced,
HUMINT is still
the gold standard.
It's the only way you can
get into the heads of leaders
and discover what
we call the plans
and intentions of a state.
Very important.
MALE SPEAKER: That does
make a lot of sense.
And going back briefly
to something you
mentioned towards
the beginning, which
is that these are somewhat
of a love letter to the CIA
and to your career.
One of the very few criticisms
I've seen directed at you
is that maybe your
view of the CIA
is a little bit too rose-tinted.
What would be your
response to that idea?
JASON MATTHEWS: Well, I'm
a former agency officer
and I'm writing about the
good guys versus the bad guys.
But even in the book there
are some pretty detestable CIA
officers, including
one traitor who's
trying to sell secrets
to the Russians.
And you know, a book, a
fiction, is something,
at least in my case, you
start writing Chapter One
and I have no idea where
the story is going to go.
I liken it to riding down
whitewater in a bathtub.
I just hang on and let it go.
So yeah, criticisms and another
things in various reviews,
I take to heart, but I don't
dwell on them too too much.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's probably best.
And I do think one of the
biggest praise that was leveled
at the book is
that roller coaster
ride, emotional
thriller, very exciting.
And it seems like you
had the same process
as you were writing it.
JASON MATTHEWS: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: Which is great.
And just to wrap up before
we open up to the audience,
just looking towards the
future, this is a second book.
The first book has been
picked up for a movie,
is that correct?
JASON MATTHEWS: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: Where do
you see the books going,
the characters going forward?
JASON MATTHEWS: Well,
my editor and the agents
say that there's probably
enough gas in the tank to write
one more book in a trilogy.
But each book has its
particular challenge.
The first book, obviously, I
was learning as I was going on.
I'm still learning.
Second book,
different challenges.
One has to tell the back story.
In other words, if you
pick up book number two
and have not read
book number one,
you've got to understand a
little bit about what went on.
And it's very difficult to
write a back story that's
not ponderous, and
boring, and sludgy.
So book three, the end of a
trilogy, further challenges.
How are you going to
close the episode off?
What's going to happen
to the characters?
And I know when we sold the
movie rights to the first book
to Hollywood, they
kept telling me
the F word, which is franchise.
They love a franchise.
They love "The Bourne
Identity" movies.
And if I write two, or
three, or four books,
they'll keep writing scripts
way beyond my ability to keep up
with them writing novels.
And the end of
writing of a script
is another interesting
aspect of my second career
as a fledgling novelist.
The challenge is
some screenwriter
has to condense a 400-page novel
into a 150-page script, which
is mostly dialogue and
a lot of white space.
John le Carre once famously
said, "If a book is a cow,
a movie script is
a bouillon cube."
[LAUGHTER]
JASON MATTHEWS: Squeezed
down and very intense.
So we're going
through that process
too, figuring out the movie,
a scriptwriter's doing it
and 20th Century Fox
bought the rights.
So it's another
exciting chapter.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
And I have to say,
just as we close,
I loved reading the book.
It was so wonderful, and
I'm really looking forward
to everybody having
a chance to read
the continuation in the series.
And I'm looking forward
to what's coming next.
JASON MATTHEWS: Thank you.
I hope everybody enjoys it.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
So we do have a
microphone here for you.
If you have a question,
if you could please
speak into the microphone.
And I'll turn it
over to all of you.
JASON MATTHEWS: A lot of people
say, oh, here comes the Q&A.
He's not going to
answer anything.
I'll answer any
questions that you ask.
AUDIENCE: So what
kind of experience
did you have as a
writer when you retired?
And how much of what's in the
book is really your writing,
and how much did the editor help
you really put it into a novel,
with the flow and all
that kind of thing.
JASON MATTHEWS: Good question,
and I get that question
occasionally.
And it occurred to
me after hearing
the question for some time
that CIA officers do nothing
in their career but write.
We skulk around at midnight
and get Intel from sources.
Then in the day, we write
intelligence reports.
We have to write estimates.
We have to write predictions.
After each meeting,
we have to write
what they call a Contact Report,
which is who, what, when, why,
where, atmospherics.
What's the source doing,
what's the source saying?
Sort of a mini novella, almost.
And in some cases, there's
a lot of fiction going on
in there too.
But so we have-- and
we don't realise it--
we have a lot of
experience writing.
Making the transition then to a
commercially-viable manuscript
is all about the editor.
If I build the house-- the
whole manuscript is 100% mine,
but I build the house and
he decorates the inside.
He does the interior decorating.
Very, very important.
And sometimes he has
the unmitigated gall
to tell me Chapters One
through Five are horrible,
cut them out.
Dang.
AUDIENCE: So a lot
of what most of us
know about the CIA comes from
novels like this and Hollywood.
And as someone who's
participated in both, or maybe
in all three soon to be,
how much of the real life
does Hollywood and these
types of novels represent?
One could imagine that your
average meeting with a source
is nothing but mundane,
and Hollywood and novels
tend to pull out the
ones that are pretty
exciting for obvious reasons.
But I'm curious when you were
interacting with your sources
back in your previous career,
was every one exciting?
Were half of them exciting?
Or are we talking about
the 10% of the time
where things went the wrong way?
JASON MATTHEWS:
It's closer to 10%.
Like a journalist or
reporter will be doing story,
after story, after story.
And maybe once, twice,
three times in a career,
it gets the big Pulitzer
Prize kind of reportage.
And yeah, most sources, who we
call agents, a lot of people
call CIA officers agents.
Were actually case
officers or officers.
Agents in our lexicon
refers to the foreigners
that we recruit who have
access to secrets, mostly
governmental types.
And we do we do a
lot of work on trying
to quantify their motivations
and their vulnerabilities.
In fact, we have an
acronym, M I C E, MICE,
which stands for the four
basic human motivators.
We all have them in some
degree or the other.
And it stands for money,
ideology, conscience, and ego.
And each agent, each
source, is different,
just like people,
different motivations,
different behaviors.
We had a little venal
source at one point
who said he could take a
picture of the new MiG-23.
And so he crawled
all over the plane
and was taking pictures,
and taking pictures,
and taking pictures.
The MiG-23 is one those
swept-wing fighters,
big sharp nose, and a nose
needle called a pitot tube
which measures air speed.
So this guy was crawling
around and taking pictures.
And he was calculating
in his mind
every frame was
X-number of dollars,
he was clicking,
clicking, clicking.
But being a little guy, he
started sliding off-- this
was at midnight-- he
started sliding off
the edge of the nose.
He bounced off the nose
needle, the pitot tube,
and fell on to the tarmac, and
he bent it 20 degrees downward.
He tried pushing it up,
pushing it up, pushing it up.
It wouldn't budge.
So coming back later
he told us about it.
I said, you know, you
have to steal secrets,
but the theft of the secret
has to be undetectable.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON MATTHEWS: So
what did you do?
What did you do?
I don't know.
The last picture in the roll,
he had gone down the flight line
and pulled down all the pitot
tubes to match the first one.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON MATTHEWS: M
I C E. War stories.
So to answer your question,
there are gold plated ones
and there are real
clunkers, but we
have to protect each
one of them equally.
That's an ethos
of our profession.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Which books are
your favorite books?
As you were writing,
I'm sure you
had an idea in your mind
of what makes a good book.
I'm sure you tried to
make your book match that.
Which other books or
which other authors
match that best,
in your opinion?
JASON MATTHEWS:
Excellent question.
I read voraciously, and
not just spy thrillers,
and not just commercial
spy thrillers.
I like sort of literary
fiction, and I dabble
in absolutely everything.
And as a rough yardstick--
and we've all opened a book
and after the first two
or three pages, we say,
oh, this is going to be tough.
You almost have to push through
a barrier to get going with it.
So my editor also taught me
fast start, keep it going,
each chapter should end with
sort of grace note, duh, duh,
duh, duh.
And then that makes people
turn to the next chapter.
I mean, this is what I
have, over the years,
appreciated in good literature.
The classics, Graham Greene,
John le Carre, in the genre.
Charles McCarry is fantastic,
an American writer.
Lot of thriller authors.
there are a lot of
good ones out there.
Very few of them have
actually lived the life.
And it's just like,
you want to read
a novel about
inside baseball, I'd
like to read one written
by a baseball player.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you just cringe
when you watch "James Bond"
or you read "James Bond"?
Ian Fleming.
JASON MATTHEWS: No,
it's all good fun.
It's fine.
Some US TV shows we do a lot
of cringing when we watch,
but it's all for entertainment.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you could
share back in the mid-70's,
how you got into the CIA?
And if that had always
been a dream of yours
as a child or whatnot.
JASON MATTHEWS: Thank you.
I wasn't particularly,
from kindergarten,
dreaming of being a spy or
intelligence officer at all.
I went through school, I majored
in languages and English.
I got a Master's Degree from
the University of Missouri
in Journalism.
And then after that,
I went to Washington
to start interviewing for jobs.
And I interviewed with the
Department of Interior,
of State, you name it.
Right time, right place.
I could have been writhing
ad copy for the National Park
Service.
Who knew.
One dark and stormy
afternoon, the interview
was with the agency
and I spoke a language
they needed at the time.
And you blink your eyes,
and 33 years later,
you have a career
under your belt.
So I never really set to join.
I met my wife during my first
tour and we got married.
And we're called, as I
mentioned, a tandem couple.
During the old days
of the Cold War,
the Soviets, and East
Bloc guys, and the Cubans,
in their chauvinism never
assumed that a spouse
would do anything operational.
All women did was go
to the grocery store
and push the baby in carriage.
So on any given dark
and stormy night--
I keep using that-- I'd
lead 15 surveillance
members across the
city park and Suzanne
would be coming back from
Ladies Book Club at the Canadian
Embassy.
She'd check her status, she
was black, surveillance free,
and she'd go and do
the operational act,
mark the signal, put down
a package, meet a person.
They never knew what hit them.
And it was a lot
safer for me too.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So the CIA, along
with certain other intelligence
agencies, I think
have always had
a little bit of a PR problem.
I mean, the public sort of
hears about the bad things,
the things that go wrong,
and of course, they
don't hear about the good things
because you can't tell people
about the good things.
All the great successes
you can't share.
So do you feel that part
of the goal of your books
is to kind of help the
public perception of the CIA
and give them, if not sort
of real successes, at least
give them the flavor
of the kinds of things
that the agency does?
JASON MATTHEWS: Partly so.
I don't have such lofty
goals for my book,
but what I do tell
a lot of people
is that I try to put
the real juice in there
to give people a sense of a
secret life and a secret world
that many people don't exist.
So it's the career through my
eyes, but it's fictionalized.
A couple of months
ago my publisher
arranged for me to walk around
Manhattan with a "New York
Times" reporter.
And the title of the
morning was going
to be, "To See the
Streets of New York
through the Eyes of a Spy".
And the "New York Times" guy
was a little bit skeptical
and he had his notebook
out and we started walking.
And I started pointing out all
the security cameras, hundreds
of them on Sixth Avenue.
An average New Yorker walks
under these a hundred times
a day and doesn't see them.
I described how a
surveillance team
would cover us on Sixth Avenue.
We went up to Bryant Park and I
described how we look at people
and how different
demeanor happens.
And at the end of
the walk, he said
that he would never look
at New York City streets
the same again.
And he wrote a little
article in the Arts section
of the "Times".
So through my eyes,
an arcane and sort
of weird career, and hopefully
entertaining and a good yarn.
But the CIA can tend
to its own reputation.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Two part question.
Over the 33-year
career, you talked
about the MICE motivations.
Have seen any change in the
motivations of your agents
in that 33-year period,
from an ideology to money,
or money to ideology.
That's the first part.
And the second part
is, what the going rate
to betray you country, on
the money and the motivation
side of things?
JASON MATTHEWS:
In terms of MICE,
these things are pretty
universal and pretty enduring.
You know, I sometimes say that
espionage is the second oldest
profession.
And what it has in common
with the oldest professions
is that eventually someone's
going to get screwed.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON MATTHEWS: But money,
ideology, lack of ideology.
For instance,
during the Cold War,
a Soviet would come
up to you and say,
I realize this is all a lie
and I want to help my country.
I've lost my idealism,
and sign me up.
And same thing
with a conscience.
I've done terrible things and
now I want to atone for them.
And each agent who was
motivated by different things,
you have to watch them.
The person who wants
to atone for past sins
might be reckless
because he really doesn't
care how many risks he takes.
So the short answer
to your question
is that these things
seem to be universal.
Now I've never sat across the
table from someone from ISIS
and try to figure out what
motivates them, for god sake.
And that's part of the
new challenge of espionage
and intelligence work.
We've got non-state actors
and it's very, very hard
to get a handle on.
In terms of going rates, it
all depends on the person,
it depends on their access, it
depends on a number of things.
During the old Cold War
the actuarial survival rate
for a Russian who accepted
recruitment outside Russia
and then went to Moscow
and started spying for us
was 18 months.
So they didn't get a chance
to spend the money they made.
And especially then
every decade when
you have a Rick Ames or Robert
Hanssen, an American traitor
who turns over 24
names of assets,
then everyone goes to jail.
They had a room in
the Lubyanka Prison,
one side of which was lined
with massive pine logs.
That's to prevent the ricochets.
Serious business.
Life and death.
What in the world would make
anyone accept a recruitment
pitch from a CIA person?
You're asking people
to commit treason.
You're asking them to break
the rules of the country
and depending on the age,
the era and the country.
It's mortality dangerous.
There's some very patriotic,
brave people out there
as we speak.
AUDIENCE: In the New
World Order where
Asia is emerging pretty
quickly and rapidly
and China is starting to
dominate the world scene,
have you seen a change in the
way intelligence gathering
and the way those governments
and those officers operate?
Have you see a change in the
general strategy and policy?
JASON MATTHEWS:
Are you referring
to the Chinese officers?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JASON MATTHEWS: They
have for decades,
they operate
slightly differently.
This is my opinion, this
is not an official version.
They operate very patiently.
They have, what they
call, a philosophy
of counting the grains
of sand on a beach.
Universities all up and down
this west coast of ours,
Caltech here in San
Francisco, Berkeley,
filled with Chinese students
who are studying at the PH.D.
level, studying nuclear physics,
studying weapons design.
And they get their degrees and
go back to institute one, two,
three, four, in China.
So yeah, it's a big issue.
We haven't even started talking
about the cyber threat which
is another big thing.
When people ask me, what
are the national security
threats United
States has to contend
with, I say the immediate
short-term threat, number one,
I would think, is the
Iranian Nuclear Program.
If they get the bomb,
everything starts
unraveling, in the region
and internationally.
Long term, I think
China's designs, hegemony
in the Pacific, challenging US
military strength, the cyber
part of it.
Russia is still there.
Thank god Putin's still doing--
I can write more novels.
And then the wild card are
the non-state actors now
that have proliferated,
the Al-Qaedas, the ISISes,
and the Boko Harams.
It's a very complicated world,
a lot more complicated than when
Suzanne and I started working.
General answer to your question,
it's a very important question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to ask your
opinion, in popular culture
sometimes Americans
are portrayed
as having a lack
of language skills,
or having a certain
cultural deafness.
So since you have experience
with other countries, agencies,
can you confirm
that this is true?
Or do we have rivals among
other countries in terms
of needing better skills?
JASON MATTHEWS: Yeah, that's
a very humorous aspect.
There's nothing quite like
the American tourist in Paris,
you know, with their
high-top basketball
shoes and Brooklyn
Dodgers jerseys, and hats
worn backwards.
The French, they just cringe.
But it's interesting to note
that other countries have
their own sort of least
favorite tourists.
Spaniards, Italians,
and Greeks really
don't like it when the
German hoards come down
from north country and wear
sandals and black socks.
Sometimes the English
football fans,
when they descend on
Madrid during big soccer
match, a football match, are
not ambassadors of goodwill.
So each country has its
own sort of bete noire,
as far as tourists.
But Americans, I think,
are getting much more
sophisticated.
And happily, a lot of different
countries, more and more people
speak English.
In the '60s in Paris,
not too many Frenchmen
would admit to speaking English.
Now, a lot do.
I mean, it's money, and
economics, and tourism.
AUDIENCE: How has
the agency changed
over your three-plus
decades working there?
And then where do you
think it should go next?
JASON MATTHEWS: Big question.
It's changed almost
like any organization
would tend to change.
The agency came up through
the bones of the OSS
during World War II.
In the '50s and the
'60s, almost uniquely,
they recruited from
the Ivy League schools.
In fact, the Russians used
to buy all the yearbooks
of the Ivy League
universities and cut out
the pages of the
graduating seniors
and put them in their mug
books because they were sure
that at least 50% of them
would end up as CIA officers.
I mean, you graduated from Yale,
you almost had an invitation
to come into the agency.
Now, obviously, we're
much more diverse.
Recruitment standards
are a lot higher.
They're looking for 400 people
and 50,000 people apply.
The language requirements
are a lot different.
Now they're looking
for what we call
critical languages, Mandarin,
Farsi, other languages.
And they seem to be
looking also for people who
are in their second careers.
I came in straight out
of school, 23 years old.
But now they're looking
for between 27 and 35 year
olds, people with a little
more life experience.
Good aspects to that, but
also less good aspects.
MALE SPEAKER: Well Jason,
I just want to thank you
so much for your time.
I think we've all
enjoyed talking to you
and hearing from you.
It's so great to hear from
your first-hand experience.
The book certainly
reflects that.
And I wish you all the best and
thank you so much for coming.
JASON MATTHEWS:
Thank you very much.
You know, I want to take one
second to thank all you here
at Google, because
I use Google Earth
and I do a lot of my
research, and I couldn't
have done it without you guys.
I've never been to Moscow
and I learned a lot
about the Moscow streets
by walking on your backs.
So thank you very much.
Keep up the good work.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]